Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, I hope you all
enjoyed the season 4 premiere.
We’ve all been waiting so long, Peter Dinklage
probably could have just read the phone book
for 54 minutes and we’d have been happy.
So here’s what I’m going to do.
This video will be a review of the episode
with top 5 moments and my first round of the
weekly giveaway.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment.
I also explain a little more in detail in
my season 3 video I posted earlier today,
so I’ll add a link to that at the end.
Also, please don’t post any pirate links
in the comments.
I’d like to be able to work with HBO in
the future.
They do not take kindly to pirates.
So let’s get started.
Here are my top 5 moments from the episode.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Number 5 - The Melting Down of Ice
Notice I didn’t say the forging of Oathkeeper
and Widow’s Wail.
This was all about calling back to Ned Stark
and all the Starks who have fallen.
The shot started on the sheath, which was
made of a wolf’s pelt.
It was actually a pretty heartbreaking way
to start a new season.
The music was even really sad with Tywin and
his haunting gaze.
I was actually kind of proud of Jaime for
defying him in the scene that followed.
And that he tried to give oathkeeper back.
The show does this amazing job at using visual
cues to call back to earlier moments.
George RR Martin writes a lot of them in the
story himself.
But it’s up to the show to interpret those
visually and the whole forge scene was amazing.
If you want to read this chapter in book 3
it’s 32.
If you want to know more about the blades,
like Tywin said, only three people know how
to work Valyrian steel and Tobho Mott, their
smith, is the best.
Ice was Ned Stark’s blade and when it was
reforged into the two smaller ones Tobho added
a reddish black hue to it for lannister colors.
Number 4 - Oberyn Martell’s Whore House
introduction
It wouldn’t be Game Of Thrones if there
weren’t a scene in a whore house.
Take off your clothes, we’ll be here awhile.
I just loved the way Tyrion shook his head
when Oberyn invited him to his little sex
party.
Remember the way he described him.
He’s fucked half of Westeros.
The culture in Dorne is a little different
too.
Women have more social standing and being
bisexual like Oberyn isn’t as big a deal
as it is in King’s Landing.
As funny as the Tyrion introduction was, their
conversation about his secret mission to kill
the mountain is really what’s going to drive
his character forward this season.
Notice he dropped some epic knowledge on us
about Lyanna Stark too.
Remember he said, Rhaegar left Elia for another
woman and it started a war.
That was Ned Stark’s sister.
A lot of people, myself included think that
Rhaeger and Lyanna are Jon Snow’s real parents.
And Ned just hid it from everyone to protect
him.
Thus making a song of ice and fire about a
Son of Ice and Fire.
Just a theory, but one of the best I’ve
seen.
If you want to read the first Oberyn book
chapter in Storm of Swords it’s Chapter
38.
Number 3 - Jaime Gets his Golden Hand
It was so funny how Jaime just waved goodbye
awkwardly with it.
The hand itself is so iconic just like Oathkeeper
or Needle but in reality it’s just as useless
as he claims it is.
A hook would be more practical.
It seems like they’re combining a lot of
Jaime’s later chapters from book 3 with
what’s happening right now.
It’s implied that Cersei isn’t down for
twincest anymore just because she’s so fried
from everything that happened since Season
2.
But there is on really notable scene from
Chapter 62.
Something tells me that they’ll just go
for it.
It’s something to look forward to.
Number 2 - Daenerys and her Kitty Cats
It’s the shot from the trailer as cute as
it is to see her purring in her lap it’s
all about them being untameable.
The computer graphics has also evolved a lot
in the last year.
Drogon is like one of those big dogs that
thinks it’s a little lap dog.
He even snapped at her like a hungry dog would
when she tried to slow his feeding.
Imagine what’s going to happen in another
year.
Dragons that aren’t kept in captivity will
just keep growing.
It was the first episode, so I didn’t expect
them to blow their whole CG Dragon budget.
I’m really looking forward to seeing a few
Drogon action scenes like they’ve teased
in the trailer
That look on Ser Jorah’s face as he’s
staring at Drogon tells you everything you
need to know.
This will not end well for anyone.
In a battle between nature vs nurture, nature
will always win.
If you want to read this part in the books
it’s book 3 chapter 57.
And my Number 1 moment - Arya Takes Back Needle
With the way they rode out of there, you’d
think the whole world is on fire.
It’s like Arya is becoming a demon and she’s
descending into hell.
Smiling no less.
Did you see how much she smiled as she slowly
slipped Needle into Polliver’s head.
She killed the other two Lannister men that
way.
Not with a giant hack, she just very gently
massaged the blades into them.
Sh, sh, sh, that’s right.
Just be quiet and die.
Best line of the episode was her whispering
“Fine Little Blade, Maybe I’ll Pick My
Teeth With It”.
There was a really notable change from the
books here, in Storm of Swords, at the crossroads
when she got needle back, the Hound was mortally
wounded and she left him for dead.
So since they’re still riding together in
good health we’ll have to see if they split
them up anytime soon.
But personally I don’t mind, they’re so
much fun together.
Don’t you just feel like it’s Arya leading
him around giving orders.
Not the other way around.
‘
If you want to read that crossroads scene
in the books it’s book 3 chapter 74.
See how things are jumping around a lot in
the book from scene to scene.
As a bonus WTF moment we have to talk about
the Thenn’s.
I thought that Joseph Gatt was playing the
Magnar of Thenn, but it looks like they cast
someone else in that role.
Who else said that Seven line in their head
when they threw the bag down at the fire.
“What’s in the bag, what’s in the bag!”
After that all I could think about was ye
old Hannibal Lecter’s cooking blog.
I can’t remember, but up to this point in
the story I don’t think we’ve seen actual
cannibalism occur on the show.
Unless you count the wights.
And they don’t eat people, they just chop
them up.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
from the premiere.
Oberyn in the whore house?
Daenerys and the Dragons or did you just think
them including the Ser Dontos Sansa scene
was really cool.
There really are too many awesome things to
talk about in just one video.
So feel free to add stuff in the comments.
Overall I rated the episode as an A minus.
I have to save the coveted A for the biggest
and best episodes.
But as first episodes go, I loved this way
better than season 3 episode 1.
The humor was great, just a lot of really
subtle additions from the actors.
Like Tyrion just shaking his head and Nikolaj
Coster-Waldau shaking his golden hand goodbye.
One of the biggest reasons the show is so
good is because the actors are so good.
I’ll say my favorite character from the
episode was definitely Oberyn.
He’s going to be so much fun.
He’s like a wild rockstar on vacation and
King’s Landing is the hotel that he’s
going to trash.
And that line, Tell you father the Lannisters
aren’t the only ones who pay their debts.
So good.
I could talk about this all day, but let me
know what your final thoughts are on the episode,
was there anything you didn’t like.
Like I said, I’ll be announcing the winner
of this week’s giveaway in my Q&A tomorrow.
You can click here to get that video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
the video.
And you can click here for all my other season
4 videos.
Thanks so much for watching, I can’t wait
for next week.
This season is going to be amazing.
High Fives everybody!